you talked about something in your book
and that's the magic of making people
feel special and I think we all think we
do that right but we probably don't so
what are some ways aside from just
complimenting people which is great I
think that's wonderful but how can we
show either verbally or non-verbally
there's a couple of different ways one
is actually by listening most people I
won't say most people many people don't
listen when you're having a conversation
with them it's a monologue let me tell
you about me let me tell you what what I
did let me tell you about my kid let me
tell you about my project let me do if
you actually actively listen to somebody
they feel seen and heard and appreciated
I'm a big fan of gifts nothing over the
top but I taught my daughter who went in
to be an intern on the first day you
bring snacks you know what I mean you
bring cookies or muffins or something
else or afterwards you send something to
thank people you thanked people
genuinely and sincerely for giving their
time because in this business that is in
short supply so thanking people in a
genuine way not an ass kissy way sending
a little something is really nice to do
and listening to people helping people
finding a way that you can help somebody
that's huge that's how you make somebody
feel special when you do want to thank
someone is it a text message is it on
social do you tweet them hey just want
to say thank you Carol or is it an
actual email or a card purse it depends
on who you're thinking if you're
thanking somebody who's under 25 it can
be a text if you happen to know their
cell number I'm not sure why you know
their cell number but if you happen to
it can be a text it could be a private
tweet I personally think it should be an
email to them and it should be within 24
hours and it should
be a paragraph or less and some people
if if you've met with somebody who's old
school send a card but don't have
kittens on that card
don't don't have don't have anything too
cute on that card just your initial or a
thank you very simple and I think that
works too
I think you have to I think you really
have to decide who you're sending into
you